you get excited about March Madness are  you a March Madness no yeah yes an but  not really what are you excited about  I'll tell you later  well I'm getting excited about it today  I filled out my bracket for the 64 March  Madness teams yeah I also I also throw  that my bracket for these 64 people  running for president yeah I have  Gonzaga beating Hickenlooper that is  it's about the same number of people  yeah yeah it's pretty confusing yeah if  you're doing brackets this year you have  to keep in mind the college admissions  scandal yeah because it turns out half  of us sees basketball team never  actually has played basketball  they're like the 5 foot 2 inches they're  like doing a selfie as they go down  crippling naming off the brands they're  wearing yeah